I say, my brothers, it is time to say, O
you who are complaining about the worries of life and its hardships, give good news,
for your Lord has rejected the path. O you complaining about the worries of life and its hardships, give good news, for your Lord has rejected the path. He who fears the Most Gracious, Glory be to His Majesty,
will make for him a way out from every
distress.
Bilal
I have many young men now. I ride in the best car
and they wear branded clothes and travel banners and parties and desires,
and in the end they say to you, “I am bored and out
of my mind now.” It has spread among our young men and women every day. The second time we hear in the media is a young man who committed suicide, so he tried to commit suicide. The question is, “Do they lack any of the desires of
the world?” By God, what does it mean?  They lack some of the desires of
the world. What do they lack? They lack a connection with the Lord of the Earth.
Ibn Masoud says: Whoever prays between himself and God
Almighty is speaking with God. And whoever
reads the words of God, then God is speaking to the
servant. If he prays before God and says, “
God is great,” then he says, “Praise be to God, Lord of
the worlds, God Almighty.”  And God Almighty says to this servant, “
Praise be to me, my servant, God is
the Greatest,” and when the
servant, the Most Compassionate, the Most Merciful, God Almighty, says, “Glorify me,” my servant says. If the servant says, “What is the owner of the day?”
[Music]
Religion, God Almighty, he says, “Praise be to my servant,”
and when the servant says, “It is You we worship, and You we seek
help,” God says, “That is between Me and My servant.” And when He
says  Servant, guide us to the
straight path, the path of those whom You have bestowed,
not of those upon whom You have incurred wrath, nor of those who
have gone astray. God says, “That is between me and my servant, and for my servant what he asks, God is greater, and for my servant what he asks, my brothers. God is the greatest of
guidance and the greatest of all things to whom
God Almighty grants you the guidance of a person. If he enters
Paradise, he remembers while he is in Paradise, the greatest blessing.
God Almighty has bestowed favors on him in this world, then he remembers it, and
when he remembers it, he says. And they said, Praise be to God who
has guided us. God is the greatest. God Almighty says in
the Qur’an: For us, whoever does good deeds, whether
male or female, and is a believer, let us give him a good life, a good life.
And he does not have a single riyal, and
I do not see happiness in amassing
money, but  The pious is the
happy one, and God-fearing is the best
provision, and God has
more for the pious [music].